[Musique]
ce qu'on m'a demandé de faire un
discours
je vous signale tout de suite tous les
dames et messieurs que je vais parler
pour ne rien dire
je sais où penser s'il n'a rien à dire
ils feraient mieux de se taire c'est
trop facile
c'est trop facile vous voudriez que je
fasse comme tous ceux qui n'ont rien à
dire et qu'ils gardent pour eux et bien
non mesdames et messieurs moi quand je
n'ai rien à dire je veux compte je veux
en faire profiter les autres et si
vous-même mesdames et messieurs vous
n'avez rien à dire eh bien on en parle
on en discute je suis pas ennemi du
colloque
mais me direz-vous si nous parlons pour
ne rien dire de quoi allons nous parler
d'un de rien et de rien car rien c'est
paris à la preuve assez complet le
soustraire rien - rien égal moins que
rien alors si on peut trouver moins que
rien c'est que rien vous déjà quelque
chose on peut acheter quelque chose avec
rien en multipliant bon une fois rien
c'est rien deux fois rien n'est pas
beaucoup
d'accord mais trois fois rien pour trois
fois rien on peut déjà acheter quelque
chose et pour pas cher
maintenant si vous multipliez trois fois
rien par trois fois rien rien x rien
galerie 1,3 multiples par trop égale
neuf ça fait rien de neuf
parlant de choses parlant de son parlons
parlons de la situation ce n'est pas
l'eau la situation sans préciser
laquelle si vous le permettez je vais
faire brièvement l'historique de la
situation quelle qu'elle soit et
quelques mois souvenez vous la situation
pour n'être pas pire que celle
d'aujourd'hui n'en n'était pas meilleur
non plus déjà nous allions vers la
catastrophe et nous le savions nous en
étions conscients car il faudrait pas
croire que les responsables d'hier était
plus ignorant de la situation que le
sont ceux d'aujourd'hui ce sont les
mêmes oui la catastrophe nous le
pensions et est pour demain c'est à dire
qu'en fait elle devrait être pour
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs si mes calculs
sont justes
or que voyons nous aujourd'hui qu'elle
est toujours pour demain
alors je vous pose même la question
mesdames et messieurs s en remettant
toujours au lendemain la catastrophe que
nous pourrions faire le jour même que
nous les vitres on signale entre
parenthèses que si le gouvernement
actuel est pas capable d'assumer la
catastrophe
il est possible que l'opposition sont
nos pères
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]